We've been talking for months now under the
guise of the Ukraine fiasco about bribery,
bribery, and extortion committed by the president
of the United States. The Trump administration
has now gone completely beyond parody on this
issue and Donald Trump is looking into making
bribery legal. Now. When I saw the headline,
I thought this is from the onion. This is
a Saturday night live sketch, but it's not.
It's been confirmed, including by advisers
to Donald Trump. Check this out from vanity
fair. Vanity fair writes a forthcoming book
called a very stable genius. Donald J Trump's
testing of America by Washington post reporters,
Philip Rucker and Carol Lennon reports that
Trump has complained about existing rules
and that he clashed with former secretary
of state Rex Tillerson in 2017 when Trump
pushed to scrap the FCPA.
That's the foreign corrupt practices act.
It's just so unfair that American companies
aren't allowed to pay bribes to get business
overseas. Trump said, according to a passage
published by the Washington post, we're going
to change that. The law is designed to prevent
individuals and businesses in the U S from
paying money or offering gifts to foreign
officials as a way to win business overseas.
Critics of the law complain that it puts us
businesses at a disadvantage in places where
bribes are customary. Now you might think
there's no way this has to be made up and
yet Donald Trump's national economic council
director, Larry Kudlow admits that this is
something they're looking at. He says, quote,
we are looking at it. We are aware of it.
We are looking at it and we've heard complaints
from some of our companies. You know that
Nixon phrase when the president does it, that
means it's not illegal.
This is going a step further. This is if the
president wants to do it or wants his friends
to be allowed to do it, he'll change the law
to make it not illegal. This is not getting
nearly the attention that it deserves. Trump
was impeached for a fiasco that includes bribery,
extortion, although that's not actually in
the impeachment articles, and his economic
advisor admits that they are looking at making
bribery, no longer illegal or a specific form
of bribery. Anyway, imagine all of the absurd
things that this could open the door to listen.
Bribery is no longer illegal, so I shouldn't
even really be considered impeached anymore.
And again, Trump was not technically impeached
for bribery. I understand that it was abuse
of power and obstruction of Congress. I'm
kind of kidding or exaggerating, but the bribery
that Trump is trying to legalize is bribery
to gain foreign favors in places where bribes
are relatively commonplace.
This is the underlying spirit of everything
that went down with Ukraine and the Biden
smears. And of course there's a Trump tweet
for absolutely everything. Back in October
of 2016 a couple of weeks before the 2016
election, Donald Trump tweeted alongside a
picture of Hillary Clinton and an article
about her quote, pay to play collusion, cover
ups, and now bribery so crooked. I will drain
the swamp. We now know it didn't quite work
out that way. Would Hillary Clinton have tried
to legalize bribery? It's hard to imagine.
She wouldn't have done all great things. Hillary
Clinton was far too to my right. There's no
question about that. But she wouldn't have
done that. She wouldn't have appointed the
Supreme court justice as Trump has appointed.
She wouldn't have appointed the extreme and
unqualified according to bar associations,
justices, judges that Donald Trump has supported,
uh, appointed to lower levels. There would
have been really important differences. And
of course, Donald Trump wants us to believe
that he's really worried about corruption
in Ukraine while he wants to legalize bribing
officials in countries like Ukraine and others,
super believable that the priority for Trump
and Ukraine all along was dealing with corruption,
right? When he's trying to legalize more of
it here in the United States. Let me know
what you think. Leave a comment if you're
watching on YouTube. Otherwise, send me a
tweet at Dee Pacman after the break. You will
not believe or maybe you will, who is now
promoting climate change denial videos
algorithmically while decimating the David
Pakman show channel. You probably only need
one guest to figure out who that is. That's
coming up next